entre deux purs sprinteurs bel 20 on
regarde charlie chaplin ses yeux était
marron clair staline avait aussi une
maîtresse polonaise celui qui écrit cela
celui qui dépeint la médiocrité d'un
système qui a fait des millions de morts
anatolie rybakov hauteur de 77 ans exilé
banni dans les allées francs il a tout
lu tout vu et tout sud un dictateur
devenu paranoïaque et rybakov va
raconter ici commence laboratoire et son
dentiste parce que celui ci était
géniale avec une adresse sans pareil
pour soigner la guerre loi à des
analyses de lui offrir des fleurs de lui
faire l'emporter des funny gattaz de lui
offrir aussi les honneurs
jusqu'au jour où le pauvre dentiste a
soigné aussi ricol l'ennemi juré de
dynamique au palis 101 vitro le dentiste
et penguin tj les chamois de open oblige
à la peine de mort sur la place rouge
joseph staline est mort fait de plus
vastes empires du monde a succombé à 73
ans à une hémorragie cérébrale
qu'adviendra-t-il demain dans ce monde
qu'ils abandonnent divinisé par ses
fidèles
honnis par ses adversaires on peut dire
que ce soit au nom de l'homme il m en
sortir une série d'un décor ordinaire
communiqué une certaine inquiétude
lui et le vol d'une invasion de guilad
de découvrir le petit père des peuples
la stèle obiwi celui qui aime le pouvoir
le plus j'espère que cruelle cavani de
hamadan est amoral
me didier in all its et merveilles et
hypocrite pour que les jeux soient
aujourd'hui à moscou et pas seulement
moscou mais à travers ses sociétés
chacun veut dire tout ce qu'il veut
ben prétendu la transparence et la
restructuration fleuron de l'air normal
chef française humaine avec 2 millions
d'exemplaires déjà bondi au delà du
rideau de fer ou back up à skis le
premier best-seller soviétique
ce vieil homme a au moins deux mairies
il signe formidable roman d'aventurés
qu'il réussi à exorciser les bébés
mongrain pays